[Música]
123 tanteándose
no
[Música]
a
pero un punto y un punto
[Música]
de marketing radiante que para la chispa
que tuvo ella
ah
mañama no one to play son calipso left
behind kings and go to limón a baña man
and white the caribbean love
vaya man one to play son calipso ley
vigente instan con tu limón para llaman
cuando wait lugar vivían glow esta
historia baña man se pide un gallo pinto
con sustancia tortilla y salchichón el
par tender quedó confundido les sirvió
raise a fin con roto puesto amigo porque
agüita pasaban y escuchó que tocaban en
tu atrapado en el ritmo bailaba entonces
a vivir se quedó
cuánto pesa un calipso baby jane lynch
and go to limones para llamar cuando way
to caribbean
se fue en bici a esta playa chiquita
pero en coclé es la rueda mayor una
negra con cara bonita la selva y allí se
enamoró
mañana y pan alegría ni steak interesan
mañana
santi sanz hoya vaya a mariscar guascor
en baile sol caribbean y panamá no
distinguen a ver
vivir
como la historia de cómo nuestro amigo
españa man ya les voy a contar que es se
fue en un bus para la zona del que debe
y dice crucial braulio carrillo con frío
pero en el sur que iba bien dormido para
tapping pintura para postre con juegos y
libres muy in y batán se iba
convirtiendo en un monje bastaban para
mandar mi vida por un bote de nuria se
tiró este mal ya después de cieneguita
lombriz a la par de cabo y la parada
perdí mi vida
va para bodega o llegando agua lava
respiro profundo ya estaba en el mejor
lugar del mundo
vaya manera de panadería en este link
mañana sin obligar a los tanquistas
huella españa maniquíes caguas todo en
la invade soltar miriam y panamá no
distinguen happen
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esta gracia muy buenas tardes a todos y
todas gracias por estar aquí en esta
edición de tedx ex pura vida mi nombre
es josé martín rodríguez me llaman en el
mundo artístico martín son yo soy
compositor y cantautor musical y su
poemas son intérprete de música popular
y además he cursado estudios de
antropología y de periodismo yo no
compartir con ustedes durante los
próximos minutos un poquito acerca de
viajes y espiritualidad quiero hacer una
pregunta primero esta canción que acabo
de cantar es una canción de mi autoría
se llama para llamar a alguien aquí en
esta sala me puede decir qué significa
el término mañama
paña
hombre blanco exactamente la población
del caribe
los descendientes de inmigrantes de
trinidad y tobago de jamaica que
llegaron al país a finales de los 70 de
1870 para construir el ferrocarril
llegaron buscando sueños dejaron atrás
su familia sus costumbres y se vinieron
a un país difícil a una zona muy difícil
a buscarse una mejor vida y con que se
toparon bueno se toparon con un país
recién configurando su identidad
nacional y se toparon con la otredad con
esa capacidad que tenemos los seres
humanos de ver a los demás como los
otros eso en querer ir en que derivó en
que ellos también tuvieran esa misma
actitud con nosotros imagínense que no
nos dejaban pasar decirles cuando se
construyó el ferrocarril y la población
afrodescendiente no podía venir al valle
central que es esa actitud humana que
tenemos
ver a los demás como algo diferente pues
bien desde que el ser humano descubrió
la agricultura y se asentó y empezó a
tener otro tipo de actividades y no
tenía que ir se largó a buscar su comida
y empezó a tener relaciones humanas
únicamente con los suyos
pues bien sucedió la el inicio de la
civilización en ese sentido
pero qué pasa cuando se nos va ese
estado de confort que pasa cuando
encontramos la incertidumbre que es el
estado conforme yo quiero compartir con
ustedes esta charla se llama
espiritualidad de viajes porque yo tengo
10 años dedicándome a la música en vivo
y tengo muy buen trabajo en costa rica
es decir
estoy en mi zona de confort no tengo que
buscar mucho trabajo me traslado aquí en
la zona central tengo una casa si
necesito una cerveza abro el
refrigerador saco la cerveza me la tomo
pero qué pasa cuando salimos de ese
estado de confort cuando nos enfrentamos
a lo diferente ahí es donde el ser
humano empieza a crecer tres conceptos
importantísimos con respecto a la
espiritualidad
tienen que ver con la compasión con la
humildad y sobre todo con la capacidad
de ponerse en los pies del otro y eso se
llama alteridad
hace tres años aproximadamente yo decidí
salir de mi estado de confort
y agarrar mi guitarra y una mochila y
salir a viajar y lo hice por una
necesidad de enfrentarme a mí mismo en
psicología se habla de que las personas
se deprimen porque el rol y el papel que
le estamos poniendo jugar a nuestro ego
ya no funciona más o el ego se aburre de
ese rol ese estado de confort toda la
gente se deprime y empiezan las
preguntas existenciales quién soy qué
estoy haciendo aquí porque tengo un
trabajo que me permite solamente tener
ratos de ocio los fines de semana porque
me siento cansado porque siento que la
vida no tiene sentido y es porque
nuestro ego es aparte de nosotros porque
nosotros no somos el ego sino es una
parte de nosotros a ese ego le ponemos
patrones que hacen que el ego se aburra
también entonces qué sucede cuando nos
alejamos de eso cuando nos enfrentamos
al exterior cuando ya no hay seguridad
cuando ya no hay estabilidad
sucede que nos encontramos a nosotros
mismos y no solo a nosotros mismos desde
adentro sino con los demás
alteridad significa ser otro o ponerse
en los pies del otro y esa esa capacidad
que no tuvieron ni los valles central y
nos de esas épocas para aceptar a la
población afro de afrodescendiente que
venía al país a trabajar ni tampoco la
de ellos de llamarnos españas y también
relegarnos verdad como los otros
que hubiera pasado
todos nosotros hubiéramos tenido la
posibilidad de viajar cuando éramos
jóvenes de enfrentarnos a otra cultura
de enfrentarnos a otro modo de vida a
otra cosmovisión
de enfrentarnos a seres humanos como
nosotros pero que tienen una visión de
la realidad completamente diferente que
empieza a suceder cuando nos damos
cuenta que nuestra burbuja de realidad
no era la que pensábamos cuando hay
otras formas de ver la vida otras formas
de hacer las cosas otras reglas morales
empezamos a cuestionarnos a nosotros
mismos quiénes somos también y qué
estamos haciendo aquí hace tres años y
tomé la decisión de irme a viajar pero
tampoco era solamente viajar porque
viajar es muy fácil si no hace un club
de viajes lo llevan de esta ciudad a la
otra en un bus éxito se toma fotos
detrás de la ventana pero irse a los
barrios populares de los lugares donde
uno viaja ir a comer las comidas típicas
de esos lugares ir a conversar con la
gente tener un almuerzo con una familia
extranjera le permite a uno crecer
muchísimo muchísimo y entonces esos
conceptos que nos dividen como seres
humanos como el de españa' man o como el
otro en guanacaste porque como nos dicen
los guanacastecos a los valles entre él
y nos quien sabe
nos dicen cartagos del río lagarto para
allá somos son cartagos y de aquí para
allá somos nosotros los guanacastecos y
la parrandera es guanacasteca y el
tambito no tiene na que ver para pa qué
pasa con nosotros los seres humanos que
no tenemos la capacidad de vernos en la
otra persona ahí es donde empieza el
asunto de la espiritualidad y por eso
les digo viajes y espiritualidad porque
esa confrontación cultural
nos permite aceptar en su totalidad la
realidad de las otras personas
como les decía yo en costa rica tenía
tengo muy buen trabajo a mí nunca me
falta trabajo con mi arte por dicha pero
cuando me fui a viajar al extranjero y
no tenía esa agenda llena de mes con
eventos los fines de semana y yo tenía
que ver cómo me costaba mi viaje
tuve que ir a tocar música a la calle y
tocando música en la calle me di cuenta
que es un ejercicio enorme de humildad
porque yo estaba acostumbrado a llegar a
un restaurante a un hotel y cobrar por
mi trabajo por lo que yo he invertido
toda mi vida para aprender a hacer esto
que dice ahora sin importar qué tanta
gente hay o si a la gente le gustó o no
el pago estaba ahí pero sentarse en una
calle en una ciudad extranjera
y exponer el arte de uno a las personas
que van pasando es un ejercicio humildad
porque uno está en ese sentido en el
estrato social en el mismo estrato
social que una persona que vende flores
en la calle es más una persona que vende
flores en la calle le pone precio a su
trabajo yo tenía que tocar 45 horas en
la calle esperando que alguien me diera
una o dos monedas y darme cuenta que el
trabajo que yo hago como músico y como
artista no era sólo por dinero era
también una responsabilidad social
porque si algo descubierto yo con mis
años de música es que una de las mejores
formas de conectar con el corazón de las
personas y establecer vínculos es con el
arte y con la música entonces yo dije
voy a irme a viajar pero como quiero
salir de mi estado de confort no voy a
llevarme mucho dinero todos generalmente
yo viajo con una tarjeta de débito con
algunos dólares por ahí por alguna
emergencia pero siempre intentando tener
que ganarme día a día el desayuno y
tener que salir a la calle a ponerle la
cara a la gente hacer mi música para
poder vivir
alteridad es una palabra importantísima
que tenemos que aprender esa capacidad
de ponernos en los zapatos del otro la
espiritualidad de viajar
conocernos porque la raza humana somos
una sola todos los seres humanos aquí en
la china tenemos frío calor miedos
alegrías yo los invito sino a
desprenderse de sus comodidades durante
seis meses e irse del país sí por lo
menos obligarse uno mismo a intentar
tener relaciones humanas con personas
que no tienen la misma visión de la
realidad que nosotros eso es
importantísimo a mí de nada me sirve
tener en el facebook gente que esté
siempre de acuerdo conmigo porque nunca
va a haber un debate nunca deberá
creatividad
antes de despedirme y decir mejor una
canción más porque tenemos muchísimos
más expositores hoy en la tarde quiero
cantar es una canción que escribí hace
no mucho tiempo pensando en cuál era mi
labor como ser humano con mi arte y con
los viajes y de qué manera puedo yo
crecer espiritualmente a través de verme
en los ojos de las otras personas por
eso viajes y espiritualidad esta canción
que les voy a cantar se llama son
medicina y dice sí
[Música]
ay
de mis acordes de loco y sembrarán
en las esquinas del día
powell
[Música]
las canciones germinan
buscando el sol
[Música]
de bulevar donde se juntan tantas
soledades
el medio del ranking
vengo a decir que nunca es tarde mirarte
a los ojos cantar y reír bank y wells o
medicina para curar el dolor así copado
caminar de alegría importa igual son
medicina para cualquier corazón ya haya
dado la vida tu este loco de amor
con los números
frente a mi guitarra
respira el mundo clavan quejoso prisa a
veces moneda y a ratos sonrisa vamos a
pintar
melodías es la calle gris
que cante la vida
y wells o medicina
el dolor así como caminar a la idea
esto es una canción como comediante y
para sentirme como un poquito de calor
humano
[Música]
sí no
pinto es evidente que curar
poder
y wells o medicina
curar el dolor ha sido un vago caminar
de alegría
da igual su medicina
a cualquier corazón se ha dado la vida
oeste luego de amor
[Música]
12 un gran aplauso
[Aplausos]
[Música]